دعا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان نظيره
الروسي فلاديمير بوتن الى وقف اطلاق النار
في اوكرانيا من جانب واحد وذلك بهدف دعم
المفاوضات والسلام
لرئاسه الجمهوريه
السلام في اوكرانيا
الحبوب وصفحه تبادل الاسرى ومبادرات منطقه
امنه في محيطي محطه زفاره النوويه
وتنضم الان اليه من انقره مراسلتنا فرح
الزمان الشوقي لتضعنا في تفاصيل ما تم
الاتفاق عليه
ليلى هذا الاتصال ياتي ضمن سلسله اتصالات
روتينيه اعتياديه يجريها الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان مع نظيره الروسي
والاوكراني تحدث في اتصال هاتفي مع نظيره
فلاديمير بوتين ومن المتوقع ان يجري اتصال
مماثلا او على الاقل ستعلن الرئاسه
التركيه عن نتائج اتصال مماثل مع نظيره
الاوكراني يركز في حديثه مع بوت على مساله
وقف اطلاق النار الذي يصفه اليوم بانه
احادي الجانب يشير هنا الرئيس التركي الى
ضروره وجود مبادره روسيه على الاقل لتحقيق
وقف اطلاق نار جزئي بدايه يتحول الى طفل
اطلاق نار شامل بعد ذلك اطلاق عمليه حوار
تؤدي الى سلام بين البلدين ولاربما جمع
الرئيسين الروسي والاوكراني في قمه لطالما
تحدثت عنها تركيا او رغبه باستضافتها
ورعايتها و عن هذا الامر طيله الاشهر
الماضيه ويعتبر الرئيس التركي اليوم ان ا
ا وقف اطلاق النار الاحادي قد يؤسس لكل
هذه المراحل القادمه يستند اردوغان في
حديثه هذا الى ان الحوار في وقت سابق وان
تم عبر وساطه تركيا ووساطه من الامم
المتحده كذلك قد ادى بالفعل لتفهمات
واتفاقات صفقه الحبوب مثال على ذلك وقد
صدرت وقد تم تصدير اكثر من 13 مليون طن من
الحبوب من الموانئ الاوكرانيه عبر البحر
الاسود في تركيا الى كل موانئ العالم الى
جانب ذلك اتفاقيات وتفاهمات ثانيه تتعلق
بضمان امني المحطات النوويه تبادل همم
الاسرى ويقول الرئيس التركي ان هذا يعني
انه من الممكن بالفعل التوصل همم الى
تسويه ما بين الطرفين الروسي والاكراني
اعتمادا على ذلك وبوجود وساطه تركيا بشكل
الرئيس ملف اخر وهو ملف لا يقل اهميه
عن مساله الوساطه ملف الطاقه تركيا تتحدث
عن ضروره انشاء مركز لتصدير الغاز الروسي
على اراضيها ويقول الرئيس التركي انهم
سيتم اتخاذ خطوات ملموسه وتقديم خارطه
الطريق فيما يتعلق بهذا همم الصدد قريبا
الى جانب الملف السوري فهناك العديد من
النقاط التي تتفاهم عليها كل من انقره
وموسكو فيما يتعلق بمساله العمليات
العسكريه التركيه في الشمال السوري لكن
نتوقع خلال الساعات القليله المقبله ان
تصدر تصريحات او بيانات مماثله عن الرئاسه
التركيه خاصه
بالاتصال الذي يجريها الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان مع نظيره الاوكراني وسيركز
كما هو متوقع على مساله وقف اطلاق النار
والحوار بين الطرفين الروسي والاكراني
ليلى شكرا جزيلا لك فرح الزمن شوقي